generally falling down an endless chasm
is the kind of death
that usually a villain experiences
leading cause of death amongst villains
let's talk about killing iconic
characters
when is it okay when is it a horrible
mistake i think it's
really important if you want to retain
the audience for a franchise
how you kill off an iconic movie
character
absolutely critical and there are places
in movie history
where it's been done right and there are
places where it's been done
completely wrong and it's been bungled
i i i i it's it's upsetting to me i mean
first of all the death of an iconic
fictional character is already upsetting
just on its face let's talk about a case
in which it was done
incredibly well in star trek ii the
wrath of khan
you're taking leonard nimoy's character
spock
who he'd played you know for decades by
then
and you're now killing off this
character
you're killing off spock it's handled so
well
it's not a wasteful death spock dies in
an act of
self-sacrifice trying to save the crew
of the enterprise which he'd done many
times before
and skirted death and now he's you know
dying in the engine room of the
enterprise
facing his best friend jim kirk
because the important thing to remember
and this is something for screenwriters
to keep in mind
is that the death of the character is
not about the person doing the dying
it's about the reaction of the
characters that love the character
that's that's going through
and experiencing their death and so what
we got to experience as an audience
was two longtime friends and an
act of self-sacrifice spock is dying and
he gets to say his final words to kirk
and kirk gets to see his friend in
addition to that
that scene is followed up with a funeral
with some glorious music and and i mean
we didn't know at the time that they
were setting up a sequel
star trek three the search for spock
which kind of gives it away that spock
might be coming back
but be that as it may
no one's ever dead in in fiction
but the way that that death was handled
with was handled with such respect
for all the characters involved we got
it was a
satisfying in the sense that we
experienced the love that
james t kirk has for his friend spock
and then the reactions of people
who loved spock and and how they were
affected by his death
his death had meaning
conversely one of the worst deaths ever
handled in movie history
was the death of han solo in the force
awakens
you know many people were upset with the
last jedi and how
luke skywalker's character was handled
but
the thing that lost it for me was han
solo's death and the force awakens
it's not done in any sort of act of
self-sacrifice
there isn't a moment where other
characters can react
to han solo's death
he's simply you know dispensed with
by his own son ben solo with a
lightsaber to the heart
and then falls down an endless chasm
generally falling down an endless chasm
is the kind of death that usually a
villain experiences
leading cause of death amongst villains
i'm sure there's an infographic
somewhere on the internet
that will tell you this because that's
how the emperor
died in the original return of the jedi
episode six
that's how villains go out falling into
an endless chasm
we don't really see the bloodiness it's
off screen
that's how a villain goes out and to
have han solo die in that way and not
have a last moment with chewbacca
his loyal friend to not have a last
moment with
princess leia or luke skywalker
the audience was completely betrayed of
any meaning for that death
was betrayed by not being able to see
our beloved characters who just if
you're watching all the movies in in
order
a few hours ago was alive and well and
saving the universe
and my god if there was a child and we
had just finished watching return to the
jedi
i don't know that i'd want to skip to
the next movie to see what happens
because what happened how the character
of han solo was treated
in his death in the force awakens was
offensive to me
and told me that this franchise was in
the wrong hands
because you can't take a character like
that and have him go out that way
you know it's not it's not a bad thing
and this used to be yes it's a hollywood
trope
you know riding off into the sunset
was was a fine way to go
right it worked for shane it worked it
worked for many
iconic hollywood films we're gonna ride
off into the sunset
maybe we don't need to see the death we
can imagine other adventures with that
character
but their story has been told and they
can ride off into the sunset but if
you're actually going to
kill an iconic character it needs to be
done with some level of respect and
every way that that could have been
handled in a much better way which would
be the
to have some final words um they could
have even done it in that movie
he could have been mortally wounded by
ben thinking he could have
turned his son back from the dark side
to
to the light and he was mortally wounded
and you can imagine a scene with luke
skywalker and princess leia over
you know a dying han solo
and what the words that might have been
said we'll never see that now
so i i i'm just
i'm just offended by that and so i think
that that's if you look at those two
cases of spock
and his sacrifice in star trek ii the
wrath of khan just go watch that scene
and then you compare it with the scene
of han solo
meaningless without even a funeral
and even the when when when rey returns
and
you know there's the knowledge that han
solo
you know is dead she she just goes to
hug rey not not like you know chewbacca
who she's
known for decades i that i don't
understand
so i really question the thinking of
some of the people in charge
who are overseeing some of these beloved
franchises
and how that affected not just children
who these movies are really made for
children or
for older dudes like myself who saw the
classic films as a kid
and would at least like these characters
to be treated
with some level of respect
george lucas famously consulted a child
psychologist when he
toyed with the idea of making darth
vader the father
of the hero of his movie
right he he was i don't know i want to
see how this is going to affect kids
was there any vetting done by how this
might affect the audience if you're
going to handle this death in that way
and in each of the sequel trilogy movies
the deaths of the characters
are are are handled with this
not not using what i would consider to
be a respectful death which is there
needs to be
someone to react to that death that is
meaningful
in that in that character's life and of
course spock's
best friend in the universe was jim kirk
so when he made that sacrifice it was
meaningful
and han solo's sacrifice seemed like a
waste
something else that occurs to me also um
related to star wars yes a recurring
topic in conversations
that i will have with you and that i
have with my friends often
you know maybe it's a form of therapy
but but what was interesting was
that when george lucas was mapping out
the story for the empire strikes back
he realized that the audience would
never believe
that you would kill luke skywalker
so you have this lightsaber duel at the
end of the empire strikes back
and it's luke skywalker fighting darth
vader
where's the tension because we already
know he's making a trilogy
you're not gonna kill off luke skywalker
so there's really no drama or tension in
that scene
so what lucas did he's like okay since
they the audience is not gonna believe
that i would kill
luke skywalker what if
the real drama the real threat is that
luke might turn to the dark side and
because he
he he doesn't listen to yoda's advice
he doesn't complete his training he goes
off as
a as as not a fully trained jedi and
faces his greatest nemesis who he then
learns at the end of the
after losing that fight that it's his
father
could he turn to the dark side and and
george lucas believed that
the audience might believe that he would
turn to the dark side
and and therein lies the tension whereas
many of the lightsaber duels that take
place in
in the sequel trilogy are
are kind of meaningless so it's
important
for these characters and i would say
that if you're a disney shareholder
you probably care even more if you want
a franchise to to continue to exist and
be profitable
and you want to sell more han solo
shirts and whatnot
that that the deaths of iconic movie
characters
be treated with respect and
it's an opportunity not just for the
fictional characters that love that
character in that world to say goodbye
it's an opportunity for the audience to
say goodbye as well
reminds me of a film i watched recently
i think or late 90s early 2000s and it's
about a hollywood producer
and it shows a test screening and sean
penn
is one of the the characters in the film
playing
you know he is sean penn in the movie
and it's the famous thing of
at the end he gets killed but does his
dog
so they show it to this test audience
and they're horrified and it's a
horrific scene it's awful
and so that is the big dilemma in the
film do we keep that scene in
and i think robert de niro plays the
hollywood producer i think it's called
like what the hell happened or something
like that it's got an all-star cast
but where i'm going with this is test
screenings and audience feedback
if you feel this way and other fans do
as well
why was nothing done why was the respect
given to one character dying not so for
the other
i mean i mean there's um there's
actually
um interesting documentary that i just
saw about alan ladd jr called lady
uh it's it's actually uh made by his
daughter and
of course alan ladd jr was instrumental
in getting
star wars made but he famously gave
a lot of notes to to movies um
like the exorcist and whatnot like he
would give very small
notes he wasn't like telling filmmakers
what to do
he was more like okay we're watching
this in a screening room and like
okay but there's this element missing
sometimes it's you know
it's important to take that step back um
and i do believe that test audiences
test audiences can actually help improve
a film
um i know that uh you know for example
you know i mean they call them focus
groups um quentin tarantino has a more
colorful
colorful term for focus groups he calls
them focus groups
but i know i said i wouldn't swear um
but but uh but i think that i think that
it's important
to you know to
to keep those kinds of feelings and
there's a lot of feelings wrapped up
in in an audience's experience with this
that's why i think these
these death scenes are so so critical
the approach to it
i i'm just surprised that
the legacy characters from the previous
trilogy
which if you're doing a marathon or just
you know were treated so poorly
um that there there wasn't as much
thought
given to that you know
um i you know you people have invested
we're talking about the movies here but
also we're also talking about there are
comic book stories about these
characters
there are stories i've made up in my
mind
about these characters yes when i played
with action figures when i was a kid
you know um there are stories we made up
in our heads there are novels
there are radio plays there are all
sorts of stories that this that
these iconic characters have you know
have
participated in and and we've
experienced those we there's a lot
invested
so the callousness with which that was
done
is shocking to me to this day
you